I might esteem and my life completely
revolves around technology preparing my
order so they'll email me when it's
ready to pick up and not only does my
life revolve around tech so does my
youtube channel
there's everything from unboxing videos
slowed open up I do get a little
reckless when I'm out flying reviews of
some of my favorite products this is
something that I think that you will
enjoy and some that don't work so well
would you mind starting all of your
questions waiting like I just seen
hanging out with Kevin Bacon and you're
promoting a new film cop car not only is
Justino a model on the show but she was
actually on the show once weren't you
Justine I was and I won the showcase so
best of luck
[Applause]
I'm also a huge fan of video games this
game makes me so happy this is my xbox
that I made with my very own two hands
and a computer and a mouse and
illustrator we're playing Mario Kart now
I also make cooking videos look at this
a vintage Apple Smart of cooking and
when I'm not failing at baking I'm
traveling I even wrote a book talking
about my offline and online adventures
here in Chicago for my siding I'm so
excited a few
[Music]
cheers to the future
technology is incredible and so is pizza
bye